nos dicen que una partícula se mueve a
lo largo de la curva x cuadrada porque
cuadrada igual a 16 por lo que la
coordenada x cambia a una tasa constante
de menos 2 unidades por minuto
cuál es la tasa de cambio en unidades
por minuto de la coordenada que de la
partícula cuando la partícula se
encuentra en el punto 14 bueno vamos a
reescribir lo que nos están diciendo la
curva estaba escrita por equis cuadrada
ye cuadrada igual a 16 es lo que nos
dicen aquí y también nos dicen que la
coordenada x cambia a una tasa constante
vamos a subrayar eso la coordenada x
cambia a una tasa constante de menos 2
unidades por minuto así que podemos
decir que de x lo escribiré del lado
derecho
x / de t la tasa de cambio de la
coordenada x respecto al tiempo es igual
a menos 2 unidades
entre minuto y nos piden que calculemos
cuál es la tasa de cambio de la
coordenada de la partícula vamos a
subrayar eso cuál es la tasa de cambio
de la coordenada g de la partícula
entonces nos piden que calculemos de g
dt eso a que es igual si nos dicen que
la partícula se encuentra en el punto 14
bueno cuando x es igual a 1 si x es
igual a 1 y que es
4 hay alguna ecuación que podamos usar
que involucre a la tasa de cambio de x
con respecto a t que con respecto a t x
y que bueno qué pasa si sacamos la
derivada de esta función que describe la
curva qué les parece si sacamos la
derivada con respecto a t en ambos lados
de la ecuación escribamos eso
mejor moveré esto para que tengamos más
espacio vamos a sacar la derivada con
respecto a t en ambos lados de la
ecuación si en algún momento se sienten
inspirados los invito a que pause en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo ustedes
primero bueno vamos a ver del lado
izquierdo si vemos esto como el producto
de dos funciones podemos sacar la
derivada de la primera función que es la
derivada de x cuadrada con respecto a t
y eso es igual a 2x y recuerden no
solamente estamos sacando la derivada
con respecto a x sino también con
respecto a t así que necesitamos aplicar
la regla de la cadena entonces nos queda
que la derivada de x cuadrada con
respecto a x es 2x por la derivada de x
con respecto a t entonces por de x de t
y después vamos a multiplicar eso por la
segunda función que es cuadrada entonces
por qué cuadrada más la primera función
que es x cuadrada por la derivada de la
segunda función con respecto a t que
nuevamente si aplicamos la regla de la
cadena la derivada de cuadrada con
respecto a que es igual a 2 g y después
por la derivada de y con respecto a t
entonces por de g
de t de t y esto es igual a la derivada
de 16 con respecto a t pero como esto no
cambia con el tiempo es igual a 0
ahí está y vamos a simplificar esto un
poco miren ya tenemos una ecuación que
relaciona a la derivada de x con
respecto a t con la derivada de y con
respecto a t entonces déjenme reescribir
esto una vez más para que podamos
simplificarlo pues lo que queremos es
dt mejor de una vez vamos a sustituir
los valores nosotros queremos saber qué
es lo que pasa cuando x es igual a 1
entonces ya sabemos que x es igual a 1 y
x cuadrada es 1 al cuadrado así que es
igual a 1 y también sabemos que que es
igual a 4 entonces esto es igual a 16 y
esto es igual a 8 y sabemos que la
derivada de x con respecto a t es menos
2 nos lo dijeron en el enunciado esto es
igual a menos 2 ok entonces
simplificamos todo esto vamos a ver todo
esto es igual a 2 x 1 x menos 2 eso es
igual a menos 4 por 16 entonces esto es
igual a menos 64 y después tenemos todo
esto que es igual a 1 por 8 del dt que
es igual a 8
dt entonces más 8 por la derivada de que
con respecto a t y esto es igual a 0
ahora si sumamos 64 en ambos lados nos
queda que 8 por la derivada de y con
respecto a t es igual a 64 y al dividir
ambos lados entre 8 nos queda que la
derivada de y con respecto a t es igual
a 64 entre 8 y eso es igual a 8 entonces
es igual a 8 unidades
unidades
entre minuto
8 unidades por minuto y lista